if you can get your work life to be
where you
enjoy half of it that is a home
that is amazing i've made so many
foolish mistakes i have a lot count
honestly
i know people i was trained to be a
teacher
as a teacher you want your students
better than you are
wanna be happy build a life not just a
[Music]
business
hey it's evan carmichael and this
channel was created to help you overcome
the number one
challenge that is holding you back a
lack of belief in yourself
you watch these videos because you know
there's something more inside you too
you've got michael jordan level talent
at something so today let's live your
best believe life
and learn the seven best lessons from
billionaires
enjoy
okay let's kick it off with lesson
number one manage your time better with
jeff bezos
there are a lot of things that are a
waste of time you know when you think
about your life
i think i i often tell people um that i
work with
if you can get because people people
have very high standards for
how they want their work life to be and
uh and i said look if you can get your
work life
to be where you enjoy half of it that is
a home
that is amazing because very few people
ever achieve
that because the truth is everything
comes with overhead
that's reality everything comes with
pieces that you don't like
you could be a supreme court justice and
there's still going to be pieces of your
job you don't like
you can be a university professor and
it's still going to be
you have to go to committee meetings and
you have to do you know
there are every job comes with pieces
you don't like
and we need to say that's just how
that's part of it
and and and not resent those pieces or
try not to
but also try to minimize them i tell
senior executives
you should have the least stress you
know there's this weird
i think false uh idea
that ceos i'm a ceo there's this false
idea that ceos are under the most stress
well
i look at that i'm like why you're in
charge
why don't you delegate the stress it's
your choice
and uh so it's you have to figure out
how to
set up your life in such a way that you
can minimize the things
and i find people don't dislike hard
work
what people dislike and what is being
out of control like they can't control
their life they can't control
their environment this happens to me
when
i get over scheduled i hate being over
scheduled i want some time to be able to
think
and free myself we all have the same
amount of time in the world
nobody has more time than anybody else
and when you become a very successful
person
one of the things you start to get over
scheduled
you have this event you had to agree to
do this and maybe last night you were
like why did i agree to do this
i have to go on stage tomorrow i wish i
would really with my family
and you know or i hope maybe not this
case let's say that you like this one
but
in general that kind of thing happens
and so you have to guard your time and
and and try to say a little bit flexible
so that's for me it's not a waste of
time but i like
to have some freedom of movement
rather than having every minute of every
day
scheduled lesson number two know what
you don't know
with warren buffett if somebody told me
10 years ago what was going to happen
the next 10 years we could have made a
lot of money in the bond market together
you know but
but it's there's always a reason
afterwards
tomorrow's paper will say stocks went
down today because of you know but they
didn't they didn't write it this
morning's paper
stocks are going to go down today
you have to know what you don't know and
you have to make sure
that what you don't know isn't all
important i mean you know if there's
four boxes there
you want to get to what is knowable
and and and and and and which uh is
favorable
and there's things that you'll miss out
on because they belong
in other three boxes one of which will
be favorable
another one the favorable and uh the
fact that you're missing out on 90
of the stuff doesn't really make any
difference if the 10 percent you do is
right
lesson number three surrender to the
dream with oprah winfrey
everybody works hard and everybody has
their own dreams
there is there was a time where i used
to spend a lot of energy wanting things
wanting things of course it's easy for
me to say oh things don't define you
because i got a lot of things things
nice i like them but this is what i
learned
when you can surrender to the dream
you get to live in the space of the
higher power
you get to live in the space that you
purposefully have come to earth to claim
for yourself
so around 1984
i was sitting in bed one morning uh
sunday morning should have been in
church but i wouldn't
i was reading the new york times review
of the color purple and i thought whoa
this sounds like a really great book i
got out of bed in my pajamas
put on my galoshes and went to the store
to get the copy of the color purple
i read the color purple in one afternoon
got went back to the bookstore bought
every book of the color purple
i took the books to to the office and i
said to everybody y'all got to read this
book oh my god you got to read this book
color purple i needed a book club i
didn't have one
so i passed out the book to everybody i
knew please read the color purple read
the color purple
then i start to hear that somebody's
going to do a movie about the color
purple
but i don't know anybody in the movie
business by this time i was on am
chicago
i don't know anybody i start praying to
god god please help me find a way to get
into color purple
i say jesus i don't even have to have a
speaking part
i will be because i went to the movies
and i saw on the movie credits
at the last credit there's something
called best boy
so i said jesus if you just let me be
best girl
that'll be all right by me i can be best
girl
i can carry the script i can help the
people with the water i can do whatever
so i start praying for the color purple
as divine law would have it quincy jones
comes to chicago and he
is in chicago for one half of a day
because somebody has filed a suit
against michael jackson
claiming that billie jean was their
lover and that's not his song
so quincy had taken the red eye to
chicago
he was in his hotel room he was coming
out of the shower and the television
in his hotel room is on am chicago
there sits little chubby me
with my jarrett curl
on am chicago quincy jones
tells ruben cannon the casting agent i
think i
found sophia so i get a call
from ruben cannon who says i'm calling
about a movie
it's called moon song would you be
interested to come and audition
and i say i have not been praying for
moon song
[Music]
i had not been playing for moon song
i've been praying for the color purple
he said well i think you should come and
and audition so i go to audition
you know movie people they make
everything all secret steven spielberg
didn't want anybody know he was doing
color purple so
on the outside of the script it says
moon song but i know
all the words by heart
so when i open the script i know this is
the color purple jesus
this is the color purple
[Applause]
yes
i auditioned for the color purple i
can't even believe it they don't just
want me to be the water girl
or the best girl they are asking me do i
want a
part in the movie oh that i'm thinking
prayer prayer works
[Music]
prayer works but listen to this
three months pass three months is a long
time
i auditioned in february march april
may comes i haven't heard anything so i
call reuben cannon
i say mr cannon i'm sorry sir i haven't
heard anything i expected to hear
something by now and reuben cannon
african-american man says to me
you don't call me
i call you and i didn't call you
do you understand that i have real
actresses who have auditioned for this
part
real actresses and he tells me who just
left his office and i went well okay i'm
not getting that part
so i hang up the phone and i start
crying
i can't believe that god has played this
trick on me i think
this is a trick so i decide that this is
because the fat
has finally caught up with me
the fat has finally caught up with me
and now i must get rid of the fat
in two weeks
i am going to go to a fat farm
and i'm going to lose 25 pounds
i'm gonna drink a lot of green juice
i'm gonna have some cleanses and
colonics
so i i i also was trying to make
peace with it i said god
i don't understand i thought it was for
me you ever had that talk with god
i i thought it was for me i thought it
was for me
god you let me audition with somebody
named harpo
that's my name backwards jesus that was
a sign wasn't it a sign
and then three months pass and then then
reuben cannon says
real actresses have just left his office
so i start to pray on the track i'm out
on the track at the fat farm
and i am running around at the track
at the fat farm it starts to rain
y'all know how that is
but i don't even care because i am
praying to god
to help me to let it go
help me let it go because now i've
become obsessed with it and it's now
controlling my life
i start praying running around the track
and i keep hearing this noise and i i
can't there's nobody on the track but me
and i'm running around the track
and i look around and it is my thighs
rubbing together
it's my thighs
[Applause]
my thighs are rubbing together
causing this thunderous sound
there's nobody on the track so then i
really start to cry
oh lord help me help me let it go
help me let it go help me let it go god
help me let it go and you ever did this
prayer where you say okay lord i'll come
and let it go then you get up and you go
well i think i still got a little bit of
it
i did help me let it go but i am not
going to be able to see the other
actress
in my part i won't be able to see it i
won't be able to see color purple
just can never see it the rest of my
life i won't be able to see it
so then i started i don't know where it
came
from i surrender all
i surrender all
all to thee my
blessed savior
i surrender all
i sang and i cried i sang and i cried
and i prayed some more
until i could reach the point where not
only
not only will i be able to go to the
movie but i can bless
the other actress i can bless her
i can say i bless you
i bless you i bless you with this i
surrender all i
surrender all
all to thee my
blessed savior
i surrender all
and i tell you in my greatest testimony
that the instant i laid that thing down
[Music]
i'm telling you when i laid it down
when i laid it down and it didn't have
me
anymore it had no control over me
anymore
i didn't feel anything about it anymore
when i let it go
when i intentionally surrendered it to
the power
that was greater than i could ever know
the instant that happened a woman comes
running out of the cafeteria
screaming aufry
is your name all free
for 10 years nobody could pronounce my
name
i said yes she said somebody's on the
telephone for you he's saying named
spielberg
i get to the phone
he says i hear you're at a fat farm
i said no sir
this is a health retreat
[Music]
he says i'd like to see you in my office
in california tomorrow this was in
wisconsin i was i'd like to see you in
my office
and if you lose a pound you could lose
this part
no problem do i have
i'll have no problem not losing a pound
so honey i packed my bags
and i stopped at the dairy queen
i got three scoops just in case i'd lost
a half a pound
and the next day i was in steven
spielberg's office and he said
you're hired you're hired also if you
want to have unstoppable confidence
and learn from billionaires check out my
254 series they're free
the links to join are in the description
below if you're doing anything
interesting in the world you're going to
have critics the only way
if you absolutely can't tolerate critics
then don't do anything new
or interesting focus on technology
focusing on making sure the platform is
efficiency focusing
everybody makes the difference in the
platform if you ask people across the
united states
is the future going to be better than
the past
most say no lesson number four make
others happy with jack ma
i know nothing about technology i know
nothing but marketing i know nothing
about the legal
all the stuff what do you know i don't
know about people
i know people i was trained to be a
teacher
as a teacher you want your students
better than you are
you want you want your best product is
your students
you want this student to be a lawyer
that's to visit a banker that's to be
the entrepreneur that
a is a mayor you don't want don't want
this bankrupt that in the jail that is
in trouble
so you always want people better and you
have to listen to them you want to see
that
and then make the all the things to
making sure that you can
empower them you can make them cheap
teamwork you can then collaborate
so this is how we do and i find the more
you care about your team
the team will care about you and the
team will care about their customers
so i talked to all of my people early
days
don't make me happy don't love me
make your customer happy make your
customer love you
and i will love you any minute
that is very simple so everything we do
as a founder
make your customer happy get your team
make your team happy
and you will be happy lesson number five
limit mistakes with elon musk
as you look back on your career in the
space industry what has been the most
surprising or unexpected challenge that
you faced
and along those lines if you were to go
back in time and talk to your 20 year
old self
would you do anything differently
go back in time to your 20 year old self
i mean i think i'd if i could i think it
would make up my
far fewer mistakes obviously if i could
go like
here's a list of all the dumb things
you're about to do please do not do them
wouldn't we all be a very long list and
like here let me
write it down or something you know um
i mean it's hindsight's 2020. so it's
hard to say
um i mean a number of i've made so many
foolish mistakes i had a lot count
honestly um
[Music]
i mean some of these things i just wish
i like like that's
simple sort of mantra management by
rhyming
i mean it worked for homer okay um
the management by rhyming is
the thing i was saying like if the if
the schedule's long the design is wrong
we've overcomplicated the design many
times
and i think we should have just gone
with a simpler design um
with the acid test being how long will
it take to
for this to fly and if it's gonna take a
long time
don't do it do something else lesson
number six
don't focus on the money with bill gates
so you are here with your daughter who
is 21 right
and you were 21 when you became a
billionaire
is that right almost yeah all right so
around that age you were you were like
the youngest person to become a
billionaire
is that right for you yeah in terms of
my own
earning it on my own yeah right okay so
which is the most important thing yeah
so did you when you were a kid did you
did you care about money or you just
cared about technology
and that's it just happened uh mostly i
love
software uh i do remember the private
school i went to there were
other kids whose families were better
off like they had a
porsche or something but it wasn't that
that big of a deal
my thing was that i just loved doing
software i loved hiring people
and i was stunned when it ended up being
so valuable
really yeah it surprised you yeah
because i always had to be careful that
we wouldn't hire too many people i was
always worried because i was
people who worked for me were older than
me and they had kids and i always
thought what if we don't get paid
will i be able to meet the payroll so i
was always very conservative
about the finances and then when we did
go
uh public uh was i uh
30 by then uh then i was kind of stunned
at what it multiplied out to
and lesson number seven the last one
before a very special bonus clip
is expose yourself to new things with
mark cuban
the same thing i told myself the same
thing i tell everybody one
you're 21 22 23 years old right
you don't have to figure it out right
now don't try
right you spend all this money sorry
um paying to learn
now it's your chance to get paid to
learn you don't need the perfect job
you just need to go somewhere where
you'll learn and start
to be exposed to different ideas and now
it's not like you know
when when greg 40 years ago was
graduating
and me five years ago you know it was
like get a career
and you know the pressure was get a
career go work for
ibm or general motors and get a pension
those days are gone
people can't even pay their pensions
anymore and so you're a free agent
and you're always going to be a free
agent on the market you guys are the
kevin durants and lebron james
you know where you're always out there
and can go find a better situation for
yourself
do what's best for you what have you got
to lose like when i started my company
you know after i got fired by michael
yumeki
um um
you know what was go how bad could it be
i would lose my motel sixth towel
you know it was just like what have you
got to lose and yeah i
understand there's pressures from
student loans and there's a lot of
conversations we can have there
right but you know you can get a job
that doesn't have to be perfect
you can learn at that job and you guys
have the pedigree you have the brains
you have the initiative to go out and
try the next job
you know you know the good news is the
economy is good enough that it may not
be perfect but you can go job to job
don't look for the perfect answer just
look to get the experience look to learn
because all these different exposures
all the different things you learn
learning how to learn
that's what's going to give you get you
excited and juicy for for something that
you love
because once you find something you love
to do
that's when the magic happens because
when you're when you're
able to find something you love to do
then you can start work focusing on how
can i be great at this
and like greg found out he was a great
networker i like to you know
play with technology and try to do
things first you know whatever it is
that you find about yourself
then you can try to be great at it and
it's rare when people quit
things they're great at you know and so
trying those things
so that that's how i advise people don't
don't stress just go out and try
different things
now i've got a really special bonus clip
that i think you're gonna enjoy but
before that it's time for the question
of the day
i want to know what was your single
biggest takeaway from this video
and write down in the comments below
when you're going to take
action on that takeaway this week when
you schedule in
what day what time and what place you're
going to take action
you have a 91 chance of actually
following through
compared to just 35 if you just got
motivated
but never created a plan and when you
share your plan and have accountability
you give yourself an even higher chance
of following through so in the comments
below write down your single biggest
takeaway as well as your specific
plan of action because i want to
celebrate with you
you've got to differentiate yourself i
always ask myself why am i different how
am i different and i think it's very
important to be
i call them the three c's but clear
concise and confident
you have to be able to describe it in a
minute or less make it so clear the
customer really wants to make
smart decisions and they really want us
to make it easy for them
so i always say make somebody feel the
pain or
if it's not the pain which means the
problem
on why you did what you did or why
you're creating what you create then
explain to them your uniqueness and then
right after that you've got to give them
the solution
very quickly and then take it through
and say why you're the best i mean very
quickly
explain to them in just a few seconds
why you're the best option
and i find that very very helpful so in
everything i do i ask myself why am i
different
[Music]
if you want to change your life in 30
days for free check the link right below
me and if you want
seven more lessons from billionaires
click the video right there
continue to believe i'll see you soon